we are going live
and
i'm live
so let's
go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to you
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with griffin
i'm back from austin texas i'm gonna
tell you all about that had a great time
on kill tony
had an argument with rachel about the
color of khakis
i went and watched thor loving thunder
thunder and whatever i'm gonna give you
my review of that
rip jack knight the sad passing and give
me my thoughts on that and just you know
it's terrible
um and i think that's about it so
you know
welcome back
[Music]
yeah
uh
shout out shout out shout out to dopa
pod the great funk band that made that
song for me uh but before we get started
let's pay some bills uh
five cbd y'all five cbd thank you to our
sponsor five cbd five products are
shipped legally to all 50 states so you
can
even send them to a friend go to
5cbd.com
griffin and enter code griffin at
checkout for 30 off and free shipping on
your first orders
also
better help better
help
better better better help
thanks to our sponsor better help easy
and affordable online therapy get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
griffin that's better help
h-e-l-p
dot com slash griffin for 10 percent off
so here we are what's up chat we're live
live in full effect guys welcome back to
riffing with griffin
starring your host eric griffin
um oh that didn't come up oh yes it did
um and make sure again once again guys
make sure you subscribe
subscribe to the podcast hit the
notification so you know you're getting
it live you know i'm also on twitch
daily playing cod i'm started playing
fortnite it's actually the no build mode
on fortnite is actually pretty cool and
if you want to uh subscribe if you want
to help me out and be a part of the
patreon you can do that too or you can
actually be now you can also be a super
follower on
twitter if you want to be like and just
me and you tweeting at each other uh you
know special tweets just for my super
followers so you know if you want to do
that do that too any way you would like
to like support the show there's so many
different ways you can become a a
youtube member you can become a patreon
member you can become a super follower
any of that kind of stuff that that you
just want to support me i really
appreciate that my uh
my fan base is
small but strong and mighty though
strong and mighty
um let's see man little tired because i
got off a plane today i was in austin
all weekend shout out to austin texas it
was hot as hell but
good people had two shows on friday two
shows saturday they were great so shout
out to creek and cave uh they were that
was fun
um
really good time there um and but i i
got to say this man the the absolute
highlight of the weekend or just the the
trip to austin was i went and did kill
tony
tony hitchcliff's uh live podcast that
he does it's just this like sort of
weird variety show of like you know p
you know you pull he pulls names from a
a bucket and
and then people come up and they do a
minute of stand up sometimes they're new
sometimes they're old people i mean
older people who have done it already or
sometimes it's a fresh new person
and then we you know we're on a panel
and we like talk to the people and make
jokes and that kind of stuff and
i'm telling you i've done kill tony many
times this was i
it's magical out there in austin man
some it was
just
every single person that came up was
just like it they had an interesting
thing and and tony and i got a good
rapport so it was just really fantastic
man i gotta tell you i don't normally
like shout out things like this but i'm
telling you this we i mean it was such a
good time from the first comic to the
last comic the first comic this asian
guy
uh with like gold on to the last comic
this this funny female comic who
apparently had
i don't even know i'm not just it's
funny so make sure you go check that out
the kill tony uh podcast
one i think it's coming out in two weeks
the one i was on so maybe next i don't
know if it's next week or the week after
i guess two weeks it'll be the week
after but anyways check that out so that
was like super fun
um
yeah it was just it's just it's such a
different vibe in in austin so
i don't think the mecca of comedy is
ever gonna be in austin though you know
just i'm sorry to say
you know i think just new york la even
chicago even a more a really great
comedy town
uh you know i know joe rogan and
everybody that that's over there they
really want you know austin to be like
this greek and it is i mean i mean the
people really come and show up i mean
because it's new you know they love
coming to see comedy like a lot of
venues but austin the city man the
downtown where i was was just like
spectacular with like there's like some
sort of like festival or something going
on at all times they have all these food
trucks all over the place and there was
so many events going on at the same time
i was
really thankful that people came to my
show so
i mean austin's always going to be that
kind of town but i don't think it's
going to be like people are going to be
like oh you know when you wanna go see
comedy you go to austin i don't know if
that's ever gonna be a thing but you
know who knows uh but it was it was uh
it was a
really good i had a really good time you
know at the creek and doing kill tony at
the vulcan gas company so if you're ever
out in austin i i highly i really do
recommend you go check out the kill tony
show
that that it is such a good time and he
always has like you know some
guest who's like passing through town
and you you know you never knew was
gonna be
like mark norman's done it uh you know
so many so many people have done it
uh so make sure you check that out
and this is my this is my first trip
since the wedding so this was and i was
i was gone for a long time because i
left on thursday i was gone thursday
friday saturday sunday monday and i just
got back today so it was a long trip
you know i missed my wife uh but but
rachel and i were on the phone and we
had this little like disagreement and i
want to bring you guys that's what just
polls about right now so i like to i
have these blue shorts
they're blue but they're they're khaki
and i said to her i said oh yeah i'm
working i'm wearing my khaki shorts
khaki and she was like that's not khaki
she was like khakis are
it's beige brown you know those kind of
i was like i was like no
this material is called khaki
it you know
let me
i gotta do my rachel thing there yeah i
was like um and so we go into she she's
like really adamant about this and i'm
like no
like khaki pants is the name for this
style of pants
even though khaki is a color
right so then i said you know and so we
going in about it it looks like uh let
me see let me see the poll right now
what what people are saying
yeah like it's like i can't even believe
it's so close right now it's 58
yes 42 percent no
like what are you talking about you
people that are saying no so me here and
i like going in on it but then i said
well let me just google it and so here
it is i googled it
i google it let me get it oh i can't get
it over here and it says oh you guys
can't see it but it says
um i googled king khaki pants me
different colors and it says right here
what color
what colors do khakis come in
while the color khaki is always a shade
of beige tan or brown
khaki pants can come in any color
imaginable for men navy gray olive green
and black are good choices thank you
thank you
i win that one pow
khaki pants
you know
because because i have these shorts and
i always say can you give me my khaki
shorts and she's always like you don't
have any khaki shorts
oh you can't change the poll now look at
everybody trying not let me end it now
because you are y'all already lost
[Laughter]
so yeah so i was like yeah you you know
khakis they can it's that style is that
sort of like
hard cloth it's not like those like
loose cotton pants
those kind of summer pants people wear
that are like always look wrinkled
not those khakis are those like what i
don't know you wear them at target i
guess or
like you like the the
like like a ups guy
that's a whole khaki outfit i think
right even though it's that color but
it's weird this is like an english
english language problem it's so
annoying right it's like
you can't so the color khaki
and then you're like okay but then khaki
pants is like
the name
so they're not necessarily referring to
the color
it's like
carl's jr
they did this to us they fooled us
so they made a burger called the six
dollar burger
but they were only charging like four
dollars for it
right
so in your mind you think you're getting
a six dollar burger for four dollars no
you you getting a one dollar burger for
four dollars
they just named it the six dollar burger
you know what i mean
so it's like a month it's all it's that
was the most genius thing they that that
the carl's jr did at that time because
in people's mind they go oh man i'm
getting a six dollar burger for four for
four dollars it's like no you're you're
you're not you know what i mean you're
not
um
you know what i mean it's so bananas so
i mean i don't know
i mean that is what it is
yeah i'm tired guys
i'm like what do i have to talk about i
don't know
but uh i'm actually glad one of our
sponsors today is
uh i'm gonna get back to the skittles
see i know i'm sitting in front of
skittles because i do want to talk about
the skittles you know but before i
before i do that let me just do this
first um i just want to
i just want to give a shout out and uh
and uh and a sad r.i.p to
jack knight
um
comic he's only 28 years old
just you know he's such a he was such a
funny dude and and that smile on his
face here in this picture
is really
that's who he was every time i saw him
you know and it's sad to think that
he was struggling with whatever he was
struggling with
that he took his own life
you know and it's just one of these
times when like
people start talking about mental health
and i talk about it a lot i mean like
today one of today's sponsors is better
better help
um
and
what i realize is like it's it's like
you know
it's
you know it's easy to say like hey
you know
let's everybody check in on your mental
health and your mental health is
important but what i also realize is
like
like your loved ones and people in your
life
if you positively know someone in your
life is really struggling with mental
health
and they're attempting to like
do something about it or
even if they're especially if they're
not doing anything about it
it's not enough just to be like stand on
the sideline and be like hey are you
going to therapy okay good you taking
that medication oh you got some
medication great and then check out
because
that struggle is real
like that thing that happens when people
are
on medication like some of the process
is
you know
you're you
you want to feel normal
so you take some medication
this medication is subscribed to you so
you can feel normal
but there's a part of you that doesn't
feel normal because you're taking
medication so how can that that's not
normal you know this that's the feeling
of it so then when you're on it and you
start feeling good you start thinking
well you know what i'm feeling good i
don't need this anymore and then you get
off of it and then there's like some
sort of effect and then there's also an
effect when people like haven't been
taking it and then they get back on it
some of those things can affect you in a
weird way and uh you know
that sucks and then another thing i
found out about um just from talking to
people about this another effect that
happens too is that you know these
medications are trying to help you feel
like you're okay
that things are possible that you could
do things but that's a dangerous thought
process
sometimes in that coming up and coming
down because
you might have the thought i wonder if i
should i wonder if i should end it you
know and then that medication is also
helping you think yeah
uh it would be easy to do oh yeah i'm
okay i can get this done so you know
i'm no doctor or anything like that guys
obviously all i'm saying is
just look out
look out for people in your life
you know look out for them if you know
they're struggling with something and
and don't just ch don't just check out
and i know it's hard like you know we're
dealing with our own thing and it's not
our responsibility i'm just saying it
wouldn't hurt you know if like someone
especially people that are going that
are close to you especially those people
don't think it's enough just to be like
oh you went to therapy great
whoo i'm done i'm checked out or don't
think it's uh you know
you know if you find out somebody oh
such and so-and-so got some medication
for their issue don't just think okay
good because maybe sometimes if it's
somebody especially someone close to you
it might be time to be like
hey hey how's that medication going are
you really taking it you know because
then you might find out if they're
really close to you but they might be
like um you know i didn't i don't like
you know
like it's like looking on these side
effects looking at your eyes it's so
much i mean i don't have the answers i
wish i did
uh but it's a real tough it's a tough
situation and
you know i it's just i my condolences
condolences go out to jack's family and
the people that were close to him his
friends
i don't like i don't like i'm not the
guy that i don't like posting on the
internet and things like that when
something happens especially because i'm
talking about this now it's because it's
like it was a thing it affected me you
know every time i saw this kid he would
give me a hug you know he would just
give me a hug and he would laugh he
would say something or he'd make fun of
me like oh you old head or whatever you
know and it's like you know i'm the kind
of person i take it when this kind of
thing happens i take it like damn should
i have checked in on him but it's like
you can't be responsible for everyone
you know that's the hard part so i know
it's a challenge out there it's a
challenge but we're like in a village
you know we are and it's like we think
that our social media village that's the
village and you know so it's easy to let
me look good you know let me look in on
my friend hey what's up dude and then
they they say i'm good man but you don't
really know they could be behind the
keyboard or behind their phone just
crying as they're saying that so
it's sad
um again i condolences to his family his
friends the people close to him
um
yeah he was he was a real good dude he
was really funny and um you know i wish
i would have known him better you know i
really do but r.i.p to
mr jack knight
all right um
somber sadness over
okay
um yeah he was on big mouth he was a
writer
you know he's just anyways
just look him up you know um just put
some good thoughts out there for his
family and then you know you know what i
mean
anyways so guys i
i saw this thing about
skittles
so that's why i have skittles up on the
thing
i mean first of all here's the crazy
part about skittles
is there any thought process in your
head to think that skittles are good for
you
or any candy for that matter
but especially skittles
like even a chocolate bar there's got to
be a part of you that knows well i
probably shouldn't eat all of this this
can't be good for me just thinking about
sugar alone
you know just thinking about sugar alone
is like god damn i gotta stop this right
but
as i look at skittles like look at these
skittles people that are uh if you're if
you're listening i'm sitting in front of
like a picture of skittles
like
is there any thought process where you
go oh skittles are good for you no
i've never looked at a skittle and
thought to myself oh this is like
vitamin c you know so
what like
there's some kind of disconnect but
here's the thing though
we have this kind of false confidence in
organizations like the fda or even just
any company like there's a thought
process and i think that i my generation
thought like this
well if a company's putting something
out
they're not going to put out something
that's harmful to us right
and then when they would put something
out harmful we would find out and that
company would get land based it would
just be like a whole thing
but there's a thought process that like
well they you know there's a there's a
checks and balance that's what the fda
is for right there's a checks and
balance to make sure the things that
they put out are good
or at least like not as bad for you as
other things but i've never thought
skittles were like like i always felt
like well i should probably only have a
few of these even when i was younger you
know but damn skittles so apparently so
this is what's happening so skittles is
being sued there's a california lawsuit
that claims skittles
unfit for human consumption
what
and apparently there's some sort of
um
chemical in it called titanium dioxide
it's listed as an active ingredient in
skittles sold in the united states you
know
although it's been removed from candy
recipes in several european nations and
banned in several other countries
now when i hear that
like okay is there some middle ground so
there are probably places that are like
oh they just ban stuff and whatever the
reason is and then there's places that
like the united states where capitalism
is the is the main important thing but
like there's got to be a point in there
where you go well what is this
you know so then like i don't know i
should probably look up
you know what is titanium yeah let's
look that up what is
titanium dioxide
um
what is here we go
titanium dioxide also known as
titanium-4
oxide or
titania
is the inorganic compound with the
chemical formula t-i-o
whatever that is when used used as a
pigment it's called titanium white
pigment white six or c
something except all these numbers and
stuff
uh it's an insoluble solid uh although
mineral forms can appear black like what
all of that sounds like some mumbo jumbo
like should that be in my body
what
so
like what does this mean so then you
know when these kind of thing happens
when this kind of thing happens it makes
me think about well what else is like we
shouldn't be eating like what else
should not be in our bodies i mean that
gives us like a like we you know we we
become dissatisfied we become like
scared of our like our confidence in
like the uh you know the the
organizations that approve these things
we start to be like ugh i don't know
if uh this is
uh good you know what i mean
i don't know like you start to go well
what else what else have they lied about
i don't even know if i want to know
like you know what if you know it's like
there's so many things that like you we
eat that you know is bad for you right
if you had to list off all the things we
go well i eat that but i don't know like
it's probably it's probably not great
for me right so just like you know you
have donuts
uh you know
um
any kind of candy like this
you know they think like like guys in
the chat like list off some things that
you go well i eat this but it's probably
not good for me
i mean there's some people that go even
further like really specific like some
people don't like red meat or sugar you
know some people don't eat bread some
people don't eat like well so yeah they
for sure they trying to cancel skittles
man
skittles is gonna get cancelled so i you
know
but again
like really
you didn't know skittles was bad for you
but if they're saying this is harmful
like what does that mean like
i don't know the science of it
it'll be interesting to hear that like
the science of it
is like is skittles causing brain damage
is it like is this is you know is
skittles causing blindness is skin what
what is skittles doing
what is this titanium dioxide does it
what does it do
that you know
these people are suing
and then like does that like does it
mean we can all sue
like what is or is there some kind of
disclaimer on the back of a skittles
thing that we didn't read
like what wouldn't that be crazy if like
this whole time it said on the back
by opening this
bag you forego your right to sue in case
something happens
you know but i mean like the ingredients
are on the on the on the thing i mean it
makes you want to read the ingredients
of everything you put in your body
like i'm drinking this lollipop right
now you know i'm drinking salad pop
which i love lollipop but then i want to
look on the back and see what the hell
is in it man i can't
see you know you know what i i am so old
now i cannot read
this what it says
okay uh oh zero source of calories from
such and such oh here's the ingredients
purified water
um
chicory root
something artichoke
caduz rule i mean look at all this stuff
i don't know marshmallow
slippery embark naple calculus
man
but it doesn't seem like there's any
chemicals in it
green tea caffeine
dairy free caramel essence
that seems kind of sugary apple juice
lime juice organic cola flavor
extract
um
is that stevia
wait is that a cap like man have you
ever taken time
to just look and see like
what
are you putting in your body
oh man
so i'm like i'm gonna keep on this i
really want to know what is going on in
the skittles community you know
as i
excuse me take another sip of the
lollipop um
you know so whatever and and by the way
somebody in the chat leonardo rodriguez
eric we're old and fat too late
too late for that
to read everything we eat bs
hey first of all don't bring me into
your weight class
that's rude and disrespectful
what you talking about
i
i need to see pictures of you before you
start calling me fat
damn
and old too so i'm old i'm old and fat
now y'all i'm old and fat according to
chat
people ain't [ __ ] man you know that
people ain't [ __ ]
but speaking of on that note uh let's
pay some bills
um i'm gonna pay these bills can you pay
these bills pay my talent phone bills
thank you to our sponsor everybody five
cbd
i actually like this you know um
you know
uh
see five cbd i'm not a i'm not a weed
guy i don't smoke weed i don't even
drink alcohol really and so this was
like one of these things i've i tried
you know i've taken some cbd you know
you put some cbd on your on your
injuries or they go like hey try this
cbd in this it's going to make you feel
better i don't know i think you need a
little bit of the thc to make things go
and i think a little bit is all you need
for me
and uh oh again i want to thank our
sponsor 5 cbd they make a full spectrum
cbd and thc products that you can
really feel you got to try their daily
buzz gummies which now come in in sour
flavors go um it really is like
i like i said sometimes you just want to
mellow out and chill this is right in
the sweet spot man it really is five cbd
is right in a sweet spot you can just
take one and then you're just like oh
it's not like you're not gonna feel high
your head isn't gonna feel clouded which
is something that i just i i would not
want
so
and it ships legally to all 50 states so
5 cbd for everyone 5gb has been designed
high quality affordable and full
spectrum products that help you slow
things down it's a great way to put that
because that's exactly what it does it
just slows it down
uh i i use it to rest
their in in
industrial hemp is grown in america and
is u.s hemp author authority certified
five cd products are third party tested
no gmos and grain free
getting um
riffing with griffin listeners get 30
off and free shipping on their first
order of five cbd
go to
5cbd.com griffin and enter code griffin
at checkout for 30 off and free shipping
on your first order that's five cbd.com
griffin and enter code griffin at
checkout for 30 off and free
shipping check that out
um and let's go to
better help now um
and this is a word from our sponsor
better help h-e-l-p
help
you know it's oh man like
we're dealing with so much stuff um
in the last three years there's so many
things to think about people are dealing
with things in their own personal lives
and
you know we take care listen we take
care of our car there's regular
maintenance on that it's regular
maintenance on our bodies like people go
to work out to make sure they stay
strong and fit and you know
lean and and agile that's takes work i
feel like the brain works in the same
way why not do that for your brain and
there's plenty of ways to support
healthy brain like learning a new
language or taking power naps and
there's also better help online therapy
listen therapy ain't gonna solve your
problems but there's something about
organizing your thoughts and underst and
trying to figure out the root cause of
some feelings and and anxieties and
things that you might have with a
professional that can recognize those
patterns
because they really do it therapy can be
mind-blowing man because you just don't
even it's not something big sometimes
it's something little they might say
like you know you feel this way because
of of such and such and i've experienced
that myself so
i'm telling you better help has been
rachel and i used it for uh couples
therapy before we got married
um and i just
i i'm telling you i highly recommend it
and it doesn't and you don't have to be
someone that's like oh my god i'm
suicidal or whatever sometimes it's just
to really help you
work on your brain man work on and work
on your feelings and your thoughts and
your anxieties and all these things man
so i really do highly recommend better
health better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat online therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with the therapist in
under 48 hours
our our listeners here at riverwood
griffin get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
griffin that's better h e l p
dot com
slash griffin and once again thank you
to our sponsor
okay guys probably not gonna be a
big long episode today
um
no i am not high i mean these people are
you man i'm telling you the live chat is
just full of
crazy people sometimes and so go get
your betterhelp.com please
all right so uh i went and i watched
thor y'all i went and i i went and i
watched thor
um
let's get thor up on the screen
boom
so as you you remember i went and i
talked about
uh doctor strange so i've been watching
i watched doctor strange a couple more
times on disney plus because when it's
free and it's not free but when it's
available like that you know i i i
didn't like it at first i'm gonna say
this
doctor strange is a fine enough
standalone movie like you don't even
need to see anything about anything and
you can watch that movie and be like oh
wow this is actually you know it's very
action-packed and all this kind of stuff
but in terms of like being connected to
like the mcu like being like
really like
widely connected to a bunch of other
characters in movies i think
it falls short of that
so i really lowered my expectation when
it comes to going to watch thor now this
is the fourth
installment of the thor movies this
one's called thor
love and thunder so the first thor movie
was it was fine
but it was great how it was connected
from another movie had the hammer and
you know that setup going to see thor
um
you know what i mean it was fine enough
movie um you know you had natalie
portman chris hemsworth of course's door
you know so that one was fine
i thought part two was
garbanzo beans that thor dark world or
whatever the one that one was but
that movie was important for
what happened later in the avengers in
the mcu so that information you got from
there was cool i bet you if they had to
do it now that thor probably should have
been a tv show it should have been an
eight episode thing on disney plus but
they didn't have that at the time right
okay and then they came out with part
three which was um which the the fun
thor oh what was that door guys oh man
you guys are gonna make me wait
and i gotta look at them so old four
movies
[Laughter]
um ragnarok yeah there you go
ragnarok i'm not gonna spoil the movie
guys i know you guys are looking in here
spoiler alert there's no spoiler alert
needed i'm not gonna spoil the movie i'm
just gonna give you like what you would
see in the trailer anyway okay so then
now i thought ragnarok was really funny
like i'm not sure who the director was
on that but i think it is the same
director as this one i'm not sure let me
see
um
taki why i don't know how to say the
guy's name i'm not going to butcher his
name yeah it's the same director it's
the same director so what i liked about
thor ragnarok it the humor in it was
just enough it was a little it was like
because it was so different from all the
other movies like they really leaned
into it and chris hemsworth
being such a handsome in shape like just
a type type of dude you know he could
have been captain america you know what
i mean he's he got that like you know
and him and his brother are hilarious
they're always funny playing the hot
jock guy but at the same time they got
that thing so the thor character has to
me is one of my favorite characters in
the mcu movie universe it's just he's
great so ragnarok was good so this is
sort of like you know on the heels of
like everything that's already happened
so
you know as you know thor
was a big fatty and uh end game so now
you cut to now thor is like this is the
aftermath of end game remember he took
off with the guardians of the galaxy who
make an appearance in this movie and so
now it's thor having like an
existential crisis about who he is and
what you know what's his purpose and you
know it just gets into that kind of
stuff and then they bring back natalie
portman
uh and they give her like a she has her
own storyline of nonsense going on with
her
and then it's like you know you know
they they you know as you know from like
uh age age of ultron
they broke up you know that's why she
wasn't in that movie which is probably
natalie portman was probably like i'm
kind of done with this or whatever her
reasons were so
you know that's what um
whatever the thing was there you know
what i mean i don't know what was going
on there or you know behind the scenes
but they brought natalie portman back
and as you know you can see from the
posters and the trailers and all that
like look look right there that you know
she's got
the hammer and she's dressed like thor
so she's got thor powers so she
for some reason now is like she's thor
you know she's girl thor or whatever
they call it
uh and so then you know they have this
adventure so
you know
love and thunder what do i think about
the movie as a whole
it was fine i mean i don't know if
that's a winning endorsement of a movie
but i just kind of thought it was fine
and it's another one of these it was a
pretty good standalone movie
you know it's it had
like the i've i don't i don't feel like
the humor hit like it did in
ragnarok i thought ragnarok was like
super funny like in a way that was like
surprising and shocking so now you kind
of wanted that it didn't deliver that
but it tried to deliver that so i don't
know if it was the performances that
were kind of like lackluster or
i don't know but it what to me the humor
wasn't connected the way it was in other
movies um
so for whatever reason that is so so
that's a little lacking but again i
thought the movie was fine the story was
fine
you know like i said it's it's not
necessarily even connected to anything
you know we saw guardian you see
guardians of the galaxy but they're not
in the movie for that long
um
you know but you kind of get a sense
that like you know so they're gonna have
their thing and uh you know and that's
always like i like when the i like that
interaction between chris pratt
as uh whatever his character is and
hemsworth and thor you know
i i i i love that interaction they have
because they're both like these like
[ __ ] they're funny dudes you know what i
mean so it rubs off and they're both you
know they're handsome in shape guys and
they still have a great sense of humor
so i like when they're interacting with
each other and i like the guardians i
think all of the the guardians it's
great uh so so you when you see that
it's fun like i say it's not the best
okay but i'm gonna tell you the best
part about this movie the absolute best
part about thor love and thunder
is christian bale
man this dude is a good actor okay like
they did
his role
like they opened the movie up with
christian bales like so you know they do
this a lot in movies okay you know
there's no need for spoiler you're gonna
like we need to know why
the hero is needed and this is like a
thing they do in a lot of movies they
open up with like the bad guys robbing a
bank or like you know you know what i
mean like you like we like like in
batman
and batman um uh a dark dark knight you
know when we first met the joker the
movie opens up
with the joker's crew robbing the bank
so you can get it so you need to know
ooh
this dude this is you know so they
really set up it's a great like i would
have liked to have seen just that movie
about him
uh what happens why christian bale turns
you know evil or whatever quote-unquote
they give him they give him a real good
reason it's justified and he plays it
really great he really does he's you
know he i forgot what a great actor he
is and i'm reminded of this um
i'm reminded of this you know and i see
some comments in the thing it's like
like look i think that
let's say the ragnarok
comedy
percentage was it was probably at like a
85 percent hit rate not every joke is
going to hit but if you can get up there
85 90 percent you know you're like oh
these jokes are hitting in this movie it
was probably more like
65 70
maybe less if you're i'm being generous
with 70
hit rate because there are some funny
things in this movie you know there like
there are some really funny moments in
love and thunder but it just wasn't as
funny as as ragnarok so and that's what
you could compare it to because it's the
same director
i think even the same writer so but i
just want to say christian bale just
gives a really fantastic performance and
i i recommend it so i am recommending
uh love and thunder um
yeah uh i think that uh natalie portman
was good in it and there was you know
what i really liked about this movie too
and i don't want to give anything away
but i love rah-rah moments like when
something happens and you know those
kind of moments admit you go
yeah
you know what i mean like there's like
in the final battle scenes
there's one of those moments uh with
some kids and i just enjoyed it so when
you watch the movie and that moment
comes
you know you you you feel that thing you
know what i mean you feel it and uh it's
it's really good it's it's good it's a
good hero movie there's like hero uh
moments and you know like i say i got
you know chris hemsworth good for him
man you know he really he's really he
plays it great you know he really is a
great thor
you know i wouldn't want to see anybody
else be thor so like if he doesn't want
to be thor anymore i want it to go away
um i don't know if you know and you know
whatever so they brought back natalie
portman you got thor i highly recommend
christian bale he was just
he's just really good
[Laughter]
so i give this movie maybe like four
woo-woos
i don't know what we got to figure out
what the woo-woo standard is is it like
10 woo-woos is the really great movie or
or is it like the or the or the
excitement in the woo-woos is is what
makes it good so i give this like a
pretty like a pretty a good a good like
not an opening to the podcast woo-woos
but it's like a
oh what's going on here hello
[Music]
so that's what i give
thor
um yeah so it's
anybody in chat have you guys seen thor
and you know what are you guys thoughts
and do you agree with me you know uh how
i'm saying about it like i say just to
recap again on thor i think it's a fine
standalone movie if you're looking for
some big connection that's going to
build up to something with the eternals
with like you know with um
um
what's his name um doctor strange and
spiderman and all these kind of things
if you're looking for that you're going
to be disappointed but if you're just
looking for like hey i like marvel
movies i this is like pre that when they
just were making movies
this is one of those type of movies and
it's you know it's fine
i think it's a pretty good standalone
movie
and uh
i would uh you know like i say i
recommend you guys watching it all right
um
let me try to see here now so as you
know what we're doing
uh to to to close out the podcast now
is
we're getting i'm not sure i got to make
sure i want to give credit i you know i
really want to give credit to the
producers that make these songs you know
so you know once again please subscribe
to the podcast you know make sure you
get your notifications
you know what i mean make sure oh i got
some oh somebody just sent me oh this is
funny hey man jeremiah has used a bunch
of my beats on scissor brothers my
instagram is fishy beats but honestly
brother i don't care about promo at all
okay well fishy beets
fishy beach just sent a beat you know
what
we doing this live
so we're gonna grab fishy beats beat
right this second at this this is like
we're doing it live and in full effect
right now y'all so let's find fishy
beats wait where is it on my thing here
um what's his name
wait i'm getting the emails oh here we
go the email's just coming in right now
oh i thought he sent a beat or he did oh
wait he did well where is it how come
it's not showing up on my email
it's not showing up on my email that
that freaking sucks
you know
you know that's i don't know you know
it's like
th this this is like
some nonsense dude
wait you know you this is what happens
when you do stuff live
[Laughter]
uh oh here it is here it is right here i
know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna wait wait wait i'm gonna i
know exactly what to do i'm gonna put
this in the bright folder right now and
it will show up on my phone boom podcast
i love icloud i don't know if you guys
use
who uses icloud uh i put it in theme
songs boom
boom so now when i go here
i go here i do this
and it will there it is
there it is
there it is
download it
okay y'all
so this is uh he's on instagram
um i'm gonna put i'm gonna put him in
the um
i'm gonna put him in the uh the
the description
again i'm on twitch daily make sure you
subscribe check out patreon be a member
on youtube if you want any one of those
types of things to support the show i
really appreciate it you could be a
super follower on on on twitter that's
kind of dope too i kind of like that you
know
and uh you know this has been uh riffin
with griffin
uh let me get back to
let's go back to like do i want the
skittles no let's go back to this one i
like this one
i'm like yeah i like this one
let's go back you know you know yeah
let's get back to the stars
haven't seen this in a while so let's
see this this is gonna be my first time
hearing this beat from fishy beats on
instagram and we go this is what we
doing at the end of the show now is to
recap
of the show
oh yeah
yeah
this is
[Music]
is messing up and i don't know what the
hell's going on
singing mike is messing up
on this fishing bee
what was this show about
[Music]
they come in many color stands
my girl she thought she was right
turns out eric griffin had the sight
[Music]
i'm the one
i'm the only one
my singing mic ain't working that hey
i don't call her out there anyway
[Music]
love and thunder
[Music]
the man was from down under
turned out to be good
you wish it would
[Music]
do it right
if skittles is out of sight
with that titanium
oxide you get a pain in your side
[Music]
i don't know why my singing might not
working right now but i see you next
week
everybody gonna move their feet
every griffin goes
when i rap at the end it's a
[ __ ] treat
all right y'all
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
rhythm with griffin